und wir haben in dieser Zeit jemanden
hier der gestern auch gewählt worden ist
und wieder Vize-Chef der FDP geworden
ist Wolfgang Kubicki guten Morgen bei
Phoenix einen wunderschönen guten Morgen
Herr Kubicki sie haben 72% bekommen man
müsste eigentlich sagen sie sind ein
bisschen gerupft worden hier oder ja
zunächst einmal fast dreiviertel der
Stimmen noch ein paar Tage zu bekommen
ist nicht immer ganz einfach aber wir
mehreren Folge jetzt gelungen und ich
fühle mich dadurch bestätigt der
angesichts der öffentlichen Diskussion
über meine Person im Vorfeld
insbesondere von der furzen der
universalen finde ich das dann
vertretbares Ergebnis und alle
Ergebnisse Präsidium waren nicht über
laut nicht berauschen aber jedenfalls
sie sprechen da das an die juli-chefin
hat eigentlich in nahegelegt ist jetzt
mal gut sein zu lassen und nicht mehr
anzutreten da haben sie sich nicht dran
gehalten sie hat dann gestern bei uns
hier im Interview gesagt wenn sie denn
jetzt aber noch mal viel zu Chef sind
dann sollten Sie in Zukunft vielleicht
Vergleiche zwischen Herrn Harbeck und
Herrn Putin sein lassen halten sie sich
daran
ich höre immer auf das was die Funktion
der Jungen Liberalen sagt weil sie eine
bedeutende Persönlichkeit des
Liberalismus ist ich würde der Frau auch
empfehlen der Kollege Franziska
brandmann dass sie mit moralischen
Kategorien wie ich sei unwürdig die FDP
zu übertreten etwas vorsichtige umgeht
denn von mir zu erwarten dass ich
Wahlkampf mache aber gleichzeitig zu
erklären ich sei unwürdig FDP zu
reparieren ist ein Widerspruch in sich
aber lassen wir das neue Frau Brandner
wird sie heute auch zur Wahl stellen
schauen wir mal hier die Ergebnisse
aussehen wird da sehe ich zumindest ein
kleines schelmisches Grinsen bei
Wolfgang Kubicki scheint dann doch so zu
sein dass sie die Kritik nicht 100%
ernst nehmen die da aus der Partei kommt
die kommt ja auch von anderen wenn man
sich hier umhört da wird dann von
Fehltritten gesprochen da würden dann
alte Zitate hervorgekramt dass sie ein
Lauterbach als Backen bezeichnet haben
da wird darauf verwiesen dass ihre
Äußerungen auch der Partei Schaden das
heißt ein Wolfgang Kubicki jetzt für die
weiteren zwei Jahre viel zu Chef der FDP
wird so weitermachen wie bisher
ja Wolfgang Kubicki wird so bleiben wie
er ist und er wird auch deutliche Worte
finden es mag einige nicht gefallen
entscheidend ist dass unsere WLAN
gefällt denn wir müssen Wahlen gewinnen
und nicht an unsere eigenen Haltung
zerbrechen noch einmal ich höre solche
Kritik immer in der Sache können wir uns
über alles unterhalten aber persönliche
Angriffe vor allen Dingen
Altersdiskriminierung finde ich
unangemessen einer Partei die sich
verpflichtet hat von solchen
Diskriminierungen abzulassen
Altersdiskriminierung sie sind 71 es
gibt noch jemanden der ist 90 der hat
Baum der hat gesagt sie sollten es denn
jetzt auch mal sein lassen er sollte
Platz machen für den Nachwuchs etwa für
eine Frau wir brauchen mehr Jugend und
er ist ein alter Mann er ist nicht die
Zukunft der FDP was sagen Sie Gerhard
bauen
eigentlich gar nichts ich bin ja ein
junger Mann und habe Respekt vor hohem
Alter insofern muss ich mich dazu nicht
äußern okay dann haben sie sich jetzt
zumindest daran gehalten was die
juli-chefin gefordert hat dass sie ein
bisschen mäßiger sind dann im Umgang
auch vielleicht mit Parteikollegen
schauen wir mal auf die Partei auf ihre
Partei sie wollen hier heute einen
Antrag mit einbringen wo es um das
leidige Thema aus es aus FDP sich
heizungs-tausch geht sie wollen da noch
mal nachbessern und es soll einen Antrag
geben wo sie im Prinzip die Pläne von
Herrn Harbeck die durchs Kabinett
gegangen sind die die FDP ja am
Kabinettstisch auch schon mit abgeknickt
hat an die wollen sie noch mal ran
können Sie das mal erklären was das für
eine Taktik ist also wir wollen da nicht
mehr rein sondern wir werden daran gehen
müssen weil die Vorlage aus dem Hause
haben wirklich nicht mehr greifen und
schlecht ist ist ja zweimal
zurückgeschickt worden und es kam wieder
zurück und im Kabinett haben alle FDP
Minister erklärt dass sie jetzt das
parlamentarische Verfahren möglich
machen wollen dadurch
den Bundestag zugeleitet wird das aber
in Verfahren selbst noch massive
Änderungen vorgenommen werden müssen und
daran arbeiten wir ich bin sicher dass
der Parteitag heute den Verhandlern den
Rücken stärken wird doch hart zu bleiben
beispielsweise bei der Frage tatsächlich
verpflichten Wärmepumpen eingebaut
werden müssen oder auch nicht ob wir uns
auf das Alter der Hausbesitzer
konzentrieren müssen oder vielleicht
auch die Situation in verschiedenen
Landstrichen und bei den Häusern selbst
und dass wir technologieoffen sein
müssen es macht ja keinen Sinn dass wir
LG Terminals jetzt bauen die Wasserstoff
ready sein müssen aber jetzt noch mit
erdgasbetrieben werden können dass wir
Gaskraftwerke bauen die mit Erdgas
betrieben werden können aber
gleichzeitig Wasserstoff ready sein
müssen und das privaten dann verbieten
also wenn der versorgen in der Lage ist
auch ausreichend Wasserstoff anzubieten
dann können wir das machen aber auch
privaten abzuladen was der staatlich
leisten kann halt nicht für uns ist man
hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass
sie eigentlich dieses Gesetz gar nicht
wollen mit diesem Antrag glauben Sie
denn dass sie da noch substanzielle
Änderungen überhaupt rausschlagen können
ja Sie müssen davon ausgehen im
Deutschen Bundestag gibt es keine
Mehrheit ohne die FDP das müssen unsere
Koalitionspartner auch begreifen links
von der FDP gibt es keine Mehrheit weder
im Parlament noch in der Bevölkerung und
das werden wir bei den Verhandlungen
wenn jetzt gar nicht konkreten
Beratungen am Gesetzesentwurf für
deutlich machen die werden Anhörung
vornehmen wir werden Verbände hören wir
werden Betroffene hören und daraus dann
unsere Schlüssel ziehen es gibt auch ein
anderes System den Emissionshandel auch
für den Gebäudebereich einzuführen aber
darüber werden wir jetzt uns lange
unterhalten das Gesetz von Robert Habeck
wird das Parlament nicht so verlassen
wenigstens Parlament können das ist ja
ein bisschen ja die druckschiff Formel
Peter Druck der frühere Fraktionschef
der SPD nicht alles schlecht bei den
sozialen in der Vergangenheit sagt
Wolfgang Kubicki der ja auch mit grünen
äh Jamaika in Schleswig-Holstein gemacht
hat sie gelten ja eigentlich muss man
sagen als eine Art Alter Vertrauter von
Robert Habeck der solche ja Lager
übergreifenden Bündnisse für die FDP
erst möglich gemacht hat und diese
Bündnisse auch geschmiedet hat der
Partei auch neue Macht Optionen eröffnet
hat warum vertrauen sie denn dann auf
Herrn Habeck immer so drauf ich haue
nicht aufhören habe immer so drauf
sondern ich sage nur ich verstehe seine
Position er will klare Entscheidungen
der Sache haben ich will das auch wir
haben unterschiedliche Positionen das
müssen wir auch öffentlich machen und
dann setzen wir uns zusammen und schauen
was wir aus diesen Positionen machen
können wir sind bisher immer noch zu
einem guten Ergebnis gekommen es wird
auch diesmal der Fall sein selbst wenn
es länger dauern sollte aber es kann
nicht so sein dass die Überlegung der
Grünen eins zu eins im Gesetz wird sagen
sie zu den Grünen mit Blick auch auf die
Wahlen die anstehen in diesem Jahr
Bremen Hessen Bayern wichtige Wahlen für
die FDP zuletzt saß übel aus aus zwei
Landtagen rausgeflogen zweimal die
Regierungsbeteiligung auch bei ihnen in
Schleswig-Holstein abgeben zu müssen
gibt es für sie eine Art rote Linie oder
gelbe Linie wo sie sagen wenn die FDP
das in diesem Jahr nicht erreicht dann
müssen Sie die Ampel ausschalten
regierungsfähig noch gibt es mehr als
Verhältnisse darauf hindeuten wir können
Neuwahlen wenn das Schlimmste überhaupt
dann halbes Jahr Stillstand in
Deutschland also wir haben einen Zwang
zur Einigung das werden wir auch konkret
umsetzen aber ich bin da tiefenentspannt
was die Wahl dieses Jahr angeht ich habe
dieses Jahr das erste erlebt dass die
Grünen aus einer Regierung rausgeflogen
sind nicht in Berlin und dass die
klimaaktivisten völlig überrascht waren
dass eine deutliche mehr der Bevölkerung
ihre Überlegungen zum Klimaschutz Berlin
2030 nicht dahin also sofern kann man
sagen bei uns geht's langsam aufwärts
bei den Grünen geht langsam abwärts ist
doch eine schöne Geschichte interessante
These die sie vertreten ich glaube
gestern wurde auch schon darauf
verwiesen dass die FDP minimal auch in
einigen Umfragen nach oben gegangen ist
trotzdem deutlich hinter den Ergebnissen
von 2021 muss man an dieser Stelle auch
sagen und da sie die klimaaktivisten
ansprechen da kommen wir vielleicht noch
mal zum Ausgangspunkt unseres Gespräch
zurück zu ihren Äußerungen sie haben das
was auch hier im Vorfeld des
FDP-Parteitags angekündigt worden ist
der sogenannten klimakleber ja als
Versündigung an der Demokratie ja in den
Raum gestellt das sei wenn man hier
einen Parteitag etwas störe muss das
denn sein die klimaaktivisten so auch
aufzuwerten mit solchen markanten
Äußerungen zunächst habe ich nur darauf
hingewiesen dass es ein undemokratisches
wenn man demokratische Parteien an der
Willensbildung hindern will das ist doch
kein Beitrag zum Klimaschutz sondern
einfach nur dumm und auch nur darauf
ausgerichtete Öffentlichkeit zu erzeugen
das gelingt ihn immer wieder drei Leute
kleben sie auf der Straße fest und schon
und schon Wolfgang drüber ja ja nicht
nur das sondern ich kann ja wenn ich die
Zeitung aufschlage der Parteitag wird
gestört da stehen drei Leute vor der Tür
und dann heißt es wird gestört aber man
muss drauf darauf achten die demokratie
lebt von der politischen Willensbildung
und Christian seine Rede zurecht gesagt
wenn sie wirklich eine Herzensanliegen
haben sollen sie die Partei gründen und
mehr halten suchen und Mehrheiten finden
das machen sie ja nicht sein sie
versuchen mit wenigen Menschen ihren
Willen anderen auch zu nötigen das ist
rechtswidrig und im übrigen wie ich
finde Demokratie dennoch ist ja die
Frage ist es nicht
Kamera vielleicht auch mit den Leuten zu
reden als nur über sie zu reden
zumindest Herr Wissing möchte ja jetzt
mit der letzten Generation ein Gespräch
führen ich finde das sehr schön dass er
mit der letzten Generation was auch
immer das für eine Vereinigung ist reden
ich weiß gar nicht wie viel Mitglieder
die haben und wie viel Unterstützer sich
wirklich haben in der Bevölkerung ich
rede auch gerne mit mit vernünftigen
Menschen aber ich lasse mir von anderen
nicht deren Willen auf nötigen da werde
ich alles dafür tun dass das nicht Platz
greifen dann stellen sie mir vorher das
sind keine klimaaktivisten sondern
rechtsradikale die jetzt einen
Flüchtlingsheim verhindern wollen soll
ich mit denen jetzt auch reden darüber
dass das eine legitime Aktion ist oder
nicht das ist natürlich auch ein
Vergleich wo ich glaube dass die meisten
Aktivisten den empört zurückweisen
würden den sie da jetzt ziehen es geht
dürfen wenige Menschen das Recht selbst
in die Hand nehmen ja oder nein und das
kann noch so ein Heeres Ziel sein es
rechtfertigt keine Ausübung von Gewalt
sagt Wolfgang wieder gewählter Vize Chef
der FDP hier bei Phoenix im Gespräch
herzlichen Dank